وافق مجلس الوزراء السعودي في جلسته يوم
امس على قرار تحويل المؤسسه العامه للحبوب
الى هيئه باسم الهيئه العامه للامن
الغذائي وذلك لتحقيق مستهدفات الفقد
وصياغه مخطط الخزنه الاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
من الرياض الدكتور محمد العمري نائب محافظ
الهيئه العامه للامن الغذائيه للشؤون
التنفيذيه او التنظيميه الدكتور محمد
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياضه
اسال اولا عن الهدف من تحويل المؤسسه
العامه للحبوب الهيئه للامن الغذائيه
اهلا وسهلا
اعبر عن خالص الشكر وعظيم الامتنان لمقام
خادم الحرمين الشريفين وسمو ولي عهده
الامين حفظهم الله على قرار مجلس الوزراء
بتحول المؤسسه العامه للحبوب الى هيئه
الوطنيه
عامه للامن الغذائي وهذا هي اسم الحقيقه
اهتمام حكوماتنا الرشيده رعاه الله على
استقرار وتطوير منظومه الامن الغذائي على
مستوى المملكه
الحقيقه الهدف الاساسي من هذا القرار
وصدور هذا القرار هو ايجاد هيئه
اشرافيه تنظيميه متخصصه في مجال الامن
الغذائي وهذا هو الهدف الرئيسي لهذا
التحول وهذا بالتالي سيتيح اللي هذه
الهيئه القيام بدور التنسيق وتوحيد الجهود
وتضافرها مع الجهات المعنيه بمنظومه امن
الغذائي سواء في القطاعين الخاص او ممتاز
يعني كيف كيف ستختلف في المهام الرئيسيه
اليوم بين الهيئه الجديده وبين المؤسسه
العامه للحبوب سابقا دكتور
الحقيقه الهدف الاساسي من التحول اللي هو
يعني مهمه اساسيه وبارزه هو متابعه ورص
همم التطورات التي تحدث في اسواق ال همم
الاسواق الغذائيه محليا ودوليا من خلال
انشاء همم نظام همم
همم انذار مبكر شامل اا يستطيع ان يعطي
التنبؤات باوضاع الاسواق العالميه
وبالتالي يساعد في اتخاذ القرار المناسب
همم لاصحاب الصلاحيه في حاله وجود ازمات
لا سمح الله
فبالتالي هناك تقارير لحظيه وتقارير دوريه
باستمرار هذه تمكن الهيئه باذن الله في
ممارسه اعمال كبيره جدا في المرحله
القادمه
يا دكتور يعاني يعني هذه همم هذه الفتره
من ازمه امن غذائهم ان شاء الله طبعا
التطورات
السياسيه الاخيره خصوصا في ما يحدث من
اسماء روسيه اوكرانيه همم هذه الهيئه كيف
ستساهم السعوديه في همم او كيف ستساهم في
تجنيب السعوديه اي خطر لقدر الله من همم
يعني همم
من خلال همم
العمل على انشاء برنامج ونظام انذار سريع
يستطيع ان يقرا ويزودنا بمعلومات كامله عن
اوضاع الاسواق العالميه والتطورات التي
تحدث فيها هذا يساعد على بناء اتخاذ
القرارات صائبه من خلال التقارير والتزوج
بالمعلومات الوافي عن حركه الاسواق السلع
الغذائيه في العالم وحتى محليا همم
بالتنبؤ او والاخذ الاحتياطات اللازمه في
حاله
الطوارئ الى سمح الله باتخاذ القرار
المناسب الذي يضمن تحقيق الغذاء الوفير في
الوقت المناسب الدكتور همم اين هي
السعوديه اليوم من هذه الازمه ازمه الغذاء
همم العالميه او الدوليه جراء التطورات
الجنسيه الاخيره
الحقيقه المملكه بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ثم تعمل قيادتنا الرشيده
كما لاحظتم في خلال اسميتي
ازمه ارجعي حتى كورونا وعزمه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه لم تتاثر اسواق
المملكه والحمد لله كانت ال ال كل
القراءات والمقايس يدل على ان هناك وفره
في الغذاء
والمكانيات المتوفره على نطاق واسع طبعا
هذا القرار الاخير وجود هيئه متخصصه في
مجال الامن الغذائي همم سيعطي ثقل كبير
للمملكه على نطاق الدولي في حيث تصبح هذه
الهيئه ممثله للمملكه في المحافل الدوليه
في المنظمات المختلفه وبالتالي همم هذا
يعزز وجود المملكه ودورها همم المحوري في
منظومه العمل الغذائي ايضا همم النظام
الانذار المبكر الذي ان شاء الله نعمل
عليه حاليا همم سيوفر لنا قراءات مستفيضه
وهمم اليه عن حركه
همم الاسواق العالميه والمحليه وبالتالي
توفير الامكانيات اللازمه
وتسهيل اتخاذ القرار اللازم لاتخاد
الاجراءات انتم نزلتم تعملون عليه نظام
الانذار المبكر دكتور لم تنتظر حتى اللحظه
بدات المؤسسه سابقه مؤسسه العامه في في
العمل على هذا البرنامج
وفي المراحل الاخيره للاطلاق بالتوفيق لكم
ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك انضم الينا من
الرياض والدكتور محمد العمري نائب محافظ
الهيئه العامه للامن الغذائي للشؤون
التنظيميه